feeling Chester CREB is teaming up
follow my lead
I'm Danielle Costa I'm the VP of visual
effects for Marvel Studios I work on all
the movies that we have currently in
production helping guide the visual
effects teams and help them as needed
for all the films we have in production
I've been at Marvel Studios since 2009 I
started on Thor 1 and then worked on
Avengers
and has subsequently worked on every
film we've made since then this I think
is a really beloved character ant-man
and what was really cool about this
particular movie it's the first time a
female heroine got her name in the title
of the film the wasp as much as this
movie is about ant-man I think
personally it's also about the wasp as
well she really came to life in a
totally different way and we saw a whole
nother side of hope Van Dyne in this
film then we had in the first film
originally they had come up with a
design that was a little bit more like a
dragonfly ultimately we landed on
something more techy
because it really had to feel more
reflective of something that could have
been created and something maybe less
organic than the dragonfly look had been
the visual effects team always wants to
be sort of the illusion that you don't
know or kind of like a magician how you
don't want it to be an obvious trick you
want people to be just swept away from
the story and everything that they're
seeing is completely believable in a
movie like this we're going small where
you're going large where you're
integrating crazy live-action
photography with crazy CG it has to all
feel like it's working on the same
universe
while it may seem to be easier to build
visual effects into plate photography in
a way it's actually just as difficult as
having a fully CG rendered shot because
you have to be able to convincingly
integrate live-action photography with
CG elements artfully in a way that
people will believe that it's all in the
same lighting condition and they're not
going to challenge it at the beginning
of the film there is a scene that takes
place in the 80s when Hank Pym and Janet
Van Dyne are younger and they are saying
goodnight to their young daughter and
little do we know that this was going to
be the last time that young hope is ever
going to see her mother until of course
the end of the movie we've shaved as
many as 20 30 40 years off of actors
over the course of the marvel cinematic
history but the technique of unifying
actors essentially what we do on set is
we dot up the actors faces so that they
have points of reference for tracking
and then re sculpt and reshape the face
to make them seem younger the kitchen
restaurant scene is probably the first
time that we really see the wasp in
action at her fullest capacity they
pulled out the frasier lenses which can
do infinite depth of field and a lot of
these surfaces and a lot of the kitchen
environment was shot using this
particular methodology as shot where one
of the goons throws the knife at her
so that was shot at a high frame rate so
that we could really take full effect of
the dramatic throw the stunt actor did
the motion of throwing but in the end
the knife itself is CG and of course her
acrobatic maneuvering around the knife
is all CG as
obviously the wasp is CG when they're
bashing on the tomatoes and the tomatoes
are exploding that you know table
surfaces CG or the extension over the CG
and the tomatoes CG so it was it was a
really well put together blend of
live-action seamlessly integrated with a
CG environment and CG animation CG
characters the fight scene in the lobby
it's the first time we see ghosts there
would be a hero take on her performance
but the visual effects facilities would
take all of the other takes that were
surrounding it that weren't may be the
hero take use and use that to anticipate
or follow the actual solid version of
ghosts for me personally the reason why
I love that scene so much it's the first
time we get to see waa spinning like the
total badass that she is
the interior of the lab was built on a
soundstage in Atlanta which is where
principal photography happened double-a
batteries that had been scaled up in the
backgrounds to imagine that like Hank
was feeling the entire lab off of these
you know tiny little double-a batteries
that he had blown up the good thing
about ants is that there's lots of
reference about how they move how they
walk they've been there's lots of
photography available online to know
really how how their movements work for
example there was a scene where dr. bill
foster is surrounded by the ants and he
just acted that out as if they were
there and then as soon as I put the ants
back in after that
[Music]
there's seen at the end of the movie
where ant-man needs to follow the bad
guy to go get the lab that he had stolen
so he goes out into the bay using so
much energy as giant man that he can
barely keep himself together and then he
falls back into the water and it's it's
a comic scene it's really funny I think
that scene from a story point of view is
really important
a lot of that scene ended up getting
replaced digitally just to make it feel
as integrated as possible so some of the
water that he interacts with is replaced
the skies are all replaced he's a full
CG character in reality if you've ever
been swimming in the Pacific off of
California you know that it's a very
murky type of water it's not like the
Caribbean you can't see very far and so
I think they did a good job at showing
how murky it was I think if it was true
to form you probably wouldn't have seen
anything but what I think is funny about
that particular shot is how much detail
that they built how much of the bay they
built how much of his suit and how much
they rendered in all of that and then in
the end they kind of did a wash deleting
all of that great details because he
wanted to give it the you know realistic
quality of feeling like them murky
Pacific Ocean that's outside of San
Francisco the important thing when Scott
is bigger when he's small to keep in
mind is to make sure that his movement
and his animation works like the scale
that he's on it adds to the feeling of
like a ginormous character and when
they're tiny like an insect they can get
around and move quicker so when the
animation team tackled either giant man
or Ant Man they have to keep in mind not
just scaling their movements in base but
also to scale
time
this is a scene where Lewis is
travelling through the streets of San
Francisco and he gets shrunk to match
back sighs the shot where he's coming
down the street is one of the few shots
in the film where we actually did use a
Frazier lens on a car and rolled it
along the the edge of the of the street
to get the background plate reference
that we needed so that we can feel that
the street surface was actually you know
ant-man size and that you as an audience
member had gone to ant-man size as well
in the case of the dive into the quantum
realm you have to convincingly show in a
photorealistic way a dimension that of
course one could never experience in
real life the teams took great care to
figure out all the different levels of
the quantum layer so first you go
through a bacterial level which we call
the tardigrade level internally the
thing about the tardigrade level is that
there is reference for that in the real
world we are able to do microbial probes
in the bacterial level and we do have a
sense of what those things look like
where you can see you know these big
shapes of tardigrades surrounding Hank
and his pod so in this scene Hank has
just arrived at the most sub subatomic
level of the quantum realm and he's
starting to explore what this crazy
world looks like he's just arrived he's
disoriented to a degree and he's trying
to get his bearings and he's very
hopeful that he's gonna find his wife
Janet down here the textures of the
quantum realm were animated using
prismatic light spectrum and they got a
lot of inspiration from coral reefs and
various like electron microscopy I think
they looked at virus microscopy and saw
what the vibrant you know colors could
be from there and built it into a moving
plane of textures and then they applied
that texture on a moving and fragmented
topography that you're meant to feel
uncomfortable to a degree about this
crazy landscape and this wacky world I
still feel like we're continuing to
improve be better the feeling around the
office is how can we be better how can
we tell better stories hacking our
visual effects be the best visual
effects in the world I love my job I
would never want to do anything else or
work anywhere else
hey what'd I miss